según la aplicación fai hours se
cancelaron más de 2500 vuelos durante el
fin de año en eeuu debido a la falta de
tripulación porque éstas estaban en
cuarentena y también por el mal clima
los contagios en estados unidos
superaron los 500 mil casos al día antes
del inicio del año una cifra que según
analistas pudo haber sido aún más grande
porque hay personas sintomáticas que no
se hicieron las pruebas y algunas que no
tienen acceso a estas no hoy sting
secretario de defensa recientemente dio
positivo también a para el cob y ni
tendrá que hacer cinco días de
cuarentena y no diez como lo recomendaba
el centro de control y prevención de
enfermedades hace unos días al respecto
analistas dicen que va a ser un invierno
bastante complicado con un repunte de
casos en el país y los hospitales
volverán a llenarse al respecto la casa
blanca anunció además que limitará
nuevamente el acceso a periodistas en la
sala de prensa para evitar el rebrote de
contagio adentro de la residencia
presidencial hay que mencionar sin
embargo que muy pronto la administración
de alimentos y drogas de eeuu daría el
visto bueno para la pastilla contra el
cob y que podría mitigar así el impacto
de omikron